OK. So here's something that I learned about myself this last week. Today's show, we're doing a show about winners. And as we talked about this idea here at the radio show, I learned that there is something I apparently say all the time here at our office as we make the show. And I really had no idea I said this at all until a few months ago when somebody on staff pointed this out. And back when that happened, I thought, sure, yes, I guess I have said that every now and then over the years. But this week, I learned I had that wrong.
好的。上周我对自己有了一个新的了解。今天的节目是关于“赢家”的。当我们在这里讨论这个节目构思时，我发现原来我在办公室制作节目时常说一句话。我之前根本没意识到，直到几个月前有个同事指出来。那时我想，好吧，可能这几年偶尔确实说过。但本周我发现我错了。
Yeah, you say it all the time.
没错，你总是说这句话。
I am joined in the studio now by my coworker, Diane Wu. Hey there, Diane.
现在工作室里有我的同事戴安·吴。你好，戴安。
Hi, Ira. It's something that I have noticed, but I didn't talk about it with my coworkers until this week. And when I went to them and taped those conversations, everybody knew what I was talking about.
你好，艾拉。这件事我注意到了，但直到这周才和同事讨论。我去找他们录音时，每个人都知道我在说什么。
Whenever you feel like you're trying to work on a story and you're in your low point, he kind of gives you this look. And he's like, no, you're a winner. You know how, in Harry Potter, they're just like, you're a wizard, Harry? That's what he kind of does with winners.
每当你觉得自己做稿子遇到低谷时，他就会给你一个眼神，说：“不，你是赢家。”你知道《哈利·波特》里那句“你是个巫师，哈利”吗？他对待赢家也是这样。
The thing Ira always says is, let's win. We're winners.
艾拉总是说：“我们要赢，我们是赢家。”
We're winners. We can do this.
我们是赢家，我们能做到。
I think when I first started working here, as an intern, basically-- I can't remember what it was, but I had told him I don't think I can do that. And he's like, that's a loser mentality. We're winners. And then I remember thinking, oh, no, I am a winner. I like to win things. He spoke to something. That worked on me.
记得刚来这实习时，具体因为什么事我不记得了，我告诉他我觉得我做不到。他却说：“那是失败者的心态，我们是赢家。”那时我想，噢，对，我是赢家，我喜欢赢。他的话对我很有用。
I can't believe anyone actually feels that way. That's so great-- for them.
真不敢相信竟然有人会这么想。这对他们来说太棒了。
It's like a moment when you look around a table and you can see on everybody's faces that they're a little bit-- that they're tired and they're not feeling like things are going to work out. And then Ira will come in with, we got this. This is going to be great. This is going to be so easy. This is going to just be so easy. We know what we have to do. We're winners. We just have to do it. Let's win. Let's win.
就像大家围坐在桌旁，你可以从每个人的脸上看到疲惫，觉得事情可能不会顺利。然后艾拉就会说：“我们搞得定。这会很棒，这会很容易。我们知道该怎么做。我们是赢家，只要去做就行。我们要赢，我们要赢。”
I have to say, that is so weird to hear everybody talking about that. Because I think I just was saying this without thinking. I think that's why I didn't realize I was saying it and how often I was saying it. It's not this deeply calculated "I must motivate the troops" thing. It's just that some part of me, just chemically, just feels like, come on. Let's go.
我得说，听到大家这么讨论真是太奇怪了。因为我觉得我当时就是随口一说，没多想。我想这就是为什么我没意识到自己在说这句话，以及说的频率有多高。这不是什么精心算计的“我必须激励团队”的手段。只是我内心深处，生理性地觉得：来吧，我们出发。
We're winners. Let's go.
我们是赢家。出发吧。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And some people find this really motivating when you do it. But others, when you're saying this stuff about winners, it just does nothing for them. They just don't get it.
有些人觉得这很励志，但对另一些人来说，说这些关于“赢家”的话完全没用。他们根本理解不了。
Wait, really?
等等，真的吗？
Yeah. They're like, why does he keep doing this? What is he talking about?
是啊，他们会想：“他为什么要一直说这个？他在说什么？”
It's terrible. It doesn't do anything but make me angry.
这太糟糕了，除了让我生气以外没有任何作用。
This, of course, is our coworker, Nadia.
当然，这位是我们的同事娜迪亚。
It made me eyeroll. And it made me completely be like, I don't want to do this.
这让我翻白眼。让我完全不想做这件事。
The winner thing also doesn't work for our coworker, Lilly.
“赢家”那套对我们的同事莉莉也不管用。
The first times I would hear it, it was like a tell to me. I'm like, oh, shoot, I'm not going to fit here at all. This guy thinks he's a winner. All these people that I don't know very well yet are also apparently winners. Apparently, they hire for winners. And that's certainly not me. Because I think of winners-- people who think of themselves as winners, I'm like, you guys are just a bunch of tryhard narcs. And I'm not about winning. I'm very much-- I identify as a loser. I am kind of a loser. I'm a quitter.
最初听到时，对我来说是个信号。我想，噢糟了，我根本不属于这里。这家伙觉得自己是赢家。看来我还不熟的这些人也都是“赢家”。显然，他们招人就是招赢家。但我绝对不是。因为在我眼里，那些自认为是赢家的人就是一群刻意表现的势利眼。我不是为了赢。我非常认同自己是个失败者。我就是个失败者。我是个半途而废的人。
[LAUGHS] Can I just stop the tape? That is such a funny thing to hear somebody say out loud.
[笑] 我能停下录音吗？听到有人大声说出这种话真的太搞笑了。
I used to play sports kind of competitively, which I think would surprise everyone who knows me. I don't seem like someone who would play sports.
我以前参加过竞技类运动，我觉得认识我的人都会对此感到惊讶。我不像是会搞竞技运动的人。
How intensely were you playing sports?
你参加竞技运动的程度有多激烈？
OK. Well, my team in high school won state in California, my soccer team, which was a huge deal.
好吧，我在高中的足球队赢得了加州的州冠军，这可是件大事。
That's a huge deal. It's a huge state.
那确实是件大事，加州很大。
It's a huge state. And then I played soccer in college too. And then one time when I was-- I guess it was the first season of soccer in college. And we had to do a mental-- some kind of a test to test how we were mentally, some assessment.
加州确实很大。后来我在大学也踢足球。有一次，好像是在大学第一个赛季，我们必须做一个心理测试，评估我们的心理素质。
This was like some kind of personality test to see how mentally tough and competitive you are.
这就像是那种用来测试心理韧性和竞争力的性格测试。
And my coach pulled me aside afterward. And he was just like, just so you know, everyone on the team other than you was, like, upper 80s and 90s. He's like, and your score was like, 34. Your brain is not wired like the rest of the people in these teams. You're wired like a grumpy, pessimistic loser. [LAUGHS]
事后教练把我叫到一边，他说：“你知道吗？队里除了你，其他人的得分都在80分到90分以上。而你的得分是34分。你的大脑结构和队里其他人不一样。你骨子里是个愤世嫉俗的失败者。”[笑]
And he's like, I don't mind. He's like, but we got a lot of progress to make here. But it told me something about myself at that time. I'm like, I am like that. Why am I here? This is why I don't relate to these people.
他说：“我不介意，但我们还有很多进步空间。”但这让我了解了自己的那一面。我想，我确实是这样。我为什么会在这里？这就是我为什么和这些人合不来的原因。
Do you think that's still you?
你觉得现在的你还是这样吗？
Yes.
是的。
And so for years here at the show, she really didn't get it, the winners thing. But then at some point a couple years in, when we were working on that story-- I think she said it was when we were working on that story about Albertville. You remember that one?
所以多年来在节目组，她真的没能理解“赢家”那套。但在入职几年后，当我们做那个故事时——我想她说是在做阿尔贝维尔那个故事的时候。你记得那个吗？
Oh, yeah. Of course. We were traveling together and spending a lot of hours together, you and me and her and Miki.
噢，记得，当然。我们当时一起出差，花了很多时间在一起，你、我、她还有美纪。
Yeah. Super, super long days, right? At some point when we were working on that story, she felt it shift. Like, she was so worn down. And one day, you said it. And it just sounded different to her.
是的，特别特别漫长的日子，对吧？做那个故事的时候，她感觉到了转变。她当时精疲力竭，然后有一天，你说了那句话，她听起来感觉不一样了。
And now I kind of like it because I feel like I understand now that the idea is more just to help you gear up for what's ahead of you. Like, at one point, Ira was just like, it's like, we have to get up a mountain, and there are mules who are going to bring us up the mountain. And we just have to encourage these mules to drag us up the mountain. But we're the mules. So we just have to beat ourselves up this mountain.
现在我反而有点喜欢了，因为我觉得我明白了，这个概念更多是为了帮你为面前的事情做好准备。比如，有一次艾拉说，这就好比我们必须爬上一座山，有骡子带着我们上去。我们只需要鼓励这些骡子把我们拉上去。但我们自己就是骡子。所以我们要自己把自己赶上山。
And I was like, yeah, that's exactly what's happening. And it does do something to give you a burst of confidence, I guess.
我当时想，没错，确实是这样。这确实能给你带来一股自信，我想是这样的。
Ladies and gentlemen, I know how corny this idea is and gets said in a thousand locker room pep talks and Nike ads and movie speeches before the big climactic whatever, but it is nonetheless true. Deciding you're a winner, deciding you can do it has a power. It creates possibilities. And deciding you're a winner isn't just something that Americans do, but it is such a fundamental thing for so many Americans.
女士们先生们，我知道这个理念有多俗气，在一千场更衣室动员会、耐克广告和电影大片的高潮演讲里都被说烂了，但它依然是真实的。决定自己是个赢家，决定自己能做到，是有力量的。它创造了可能性。决定自己是赢家不仅是美国人会做的事，这对许多美国人来说也是极其根本的东西。
It's Muhammad Ali and Billie Jean King and Zohran Mamdani but also Donald Trump and Simone Biles and Frank Sinatra. And so much of this country was made by outsiders who traveled here, so many of them just deciding and believing that they could succeed here and have a better life. Maybe that's why this mentality is so common here and feels so American. We are the mule.
这是穆罕默德·阿里、比莉·简·金和佐兰·马姆达尼的精神，也是唐纳德·特朗普、西蒙·拜尔斯和弗兰克·辛纳屈的精神。这个国家很大程度上是由那些移居到此的局外人建立的，他们中的许多人只是决定并相信自己可以在这里成功，过上更好的生活。也许这就是为什么这种心态在这里如此普遍，并让人感觉如此“美国”。我们就是那头骡子。
Today on our show-- winners. We're going to watch them in action in a tough game, where the rules are literally being made up as they go along. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目主题是——赢家。我们将在一场艰难的游戏中看他们如何行动，在那场游戏中，规则完全是在行进中制定的。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act One, Winners Welcome. We've done a lot of stories this year about people who were negatively affected, in one way or another, by big new policies rolled out by the Trump administration-- people who've been detained by ICE, or who lost government jobs, or had their funding cut, or been kicked out of the military, or found their Black student union can no longer be called a Black student union.
这是《美国生活》，第一幕，欢迎赢家。今年我们做了很多关于那些受到负面影响的人的故事，他们或多或少受到了特朗普政府新政策的影响——比如被移民及海关执法局（ICE）拘留的人，失去政府工作的人，资金被削减的人，被军队踢出的人，或者发现他们的黑人学生会不能再被称为黑人学生会的人。
But the story we're about to tell is about other people-- people who saw new Trump administration policies, who saw one of the hundreds of executive orders that the president has signed. And they thought to themselves, holy cow, that's great news for me, personally. They were targeted by some new policy and happy about it.
但我们要讲的这个故事是关于另一群人——那些看到了特朗普政府的新政策，看到了总统签署的数百项行政命令之一的人。他们心想：“天哪，这对我也许是个好消息。”他们是某些新政策的目标，并且为此感到高兴。
This particular group of winners is in the news this week, but Chana Joffe-Walt has been following the story from the beginning through many turns. You're about to hear drama, suspense, rivalry. This is a true story about trying to win in 2025 America. Her story begins, as so many do these days, with an announcement from the White House. Here's Chana.
这群特殊的“赢家”本周上了新闻。查娜·乔菲-沃尔特一直追踪这个故事的始末，经历了许多曲折。你即将听到的是戏剧性、悬疑和竞争。这是一个关于在2025年的美国试图赢的故事。她的故事像今天许多故事一样，始于白宫的一则公告。请听查娜的报道。
The word went out in February of this year. It was Executive Order 14204. Title-- Addressing Egregious Actions of the Republic of South Africa.
今年二月消息传出。那是第14204号行政命令。标题是——《针对南非共和国的恶劣行为》。
Do you remember where you were?
你还记得当时你在哪里吗？
Yeah. So that's actually a funny story. I was asleep, obviously. It was South African time. It was day during the US but night here. And I woke up. And it was, like, 3:00 in the morning. And I saw a media storm. So I think I was one of the first Afrikaners to actually see it.
是的，那其实是个有趣的故事。当时我显然在睡觉。那是南非时间。美国是白天，但这里是晚上。我醒来时大概是凌晨3点，我看到了媒体轰炸。所以我认为我是最早看到它的南非荷兰人之一。
Joost Strydom-- fresh faced, serious, Afrikaner, a white minority in South Africa. Joost is the leader of a whites-only town. Yes, one of those exists. It's all Afrikaners in the Northern Cape in the desert. It's called Orania. Joost grew up there. So it's 3:00 AM, and he's reading this executive order from President Trump. It talked about a, quote, "shocking disregard of citizens' rights" happening in South Africa, "unjust discrimination" against Afrikaners.
尤斯特·斯特里多姆——面孔年轻、神情严肃的南非荷兰人，南非的一个白人少数族裔。尤斯特是一个全白人小镇的领导者。没错，确实存在这样的地方。那是位于北开普省沙漠里的全南非荷兰人居住地，叫奥拉尼亚。尤斯特在那里长大。所以那是凌晨3点，他正在读特朗普总统签署的这份行政命令。它提到了南非正在发生所谓的“对公民权利的令人震惊的漠视”以及对南非荷兰人的“不正当歧视”。
Joost has been talking about these exact issues-- the egregious actions mentioned in the executive order-- for years. President Trump was using the same words he uses, calling for the same changes.
尤斯特多年来一直在谈论这些具体问题——即行政命令中提到的恶劣行为。特朗普总统使用的词汇和他一样，呼吁的改革也相同。
We could almost not believe our eyes when we saw the president of the mightiest country in the world just mentioning us specifically.
当我们看到世界上最强大国家的总统专门提到我们时，我们简直不敢相信自己的眼睛。
It sounds like you go to, like, a rock concert. And your favorite band up there is like, happy birthday, Billy. And you're like, oh my god, I'm Billy.
这听起来就像你去听摇滚演唱会，你最喜欢的乐队在台上说：“生日快乐，比利。”然后你会想：“天哪，我就是比利。”
[LAUGHS] Yes, it's basically that feeling.
[笑] 是的，基本就是那种感觉。
An incredible win, a high-- and then, suddenly, a bit of a crash. A few sentences later in the executive order, Joost saw the order's solution to address this unjust targeting of Afrikaners was for the United States to resettle, quote, "Afrikaner refugees escaping government-sponsored, race-based discrimination," end quote.
一个不可思议的胜利，一个高峰——然后，突然间，有点跌落。在行政命令的几句之后，尤斯特看到了针对南非荷兰人这种不公正对待的解决方案：美国将重新安置所谓的“逃离政府支持的种族歧视的南非荷兰人难民”。
So that was-- I think it was, for all of us, a big, big, big surprise.
所以，这对我们所有人来说，都是一个巨大的、巨大的、巨大的惊喜。
Refugees? Joost thought-- as in, leave the country? He didn't want to leave the country. He wanted President Trump to help Afrikaners get their own territory in Africa. And he wanted President Trump to pressure the South African government to get rid of what he sees as racist laws against white people. He was not looking to come to the US and become American.
难民？尤斯特心想——是指离开这个国家？他不想离开这个国家。他希望特朗普总统能帮助南非荷兰人在非洲获得属于他们自己的领土。他希望特朗普总统向南非政府施压，消除他眼中针对白人的种族歧视法律。他并不想来美国成为美国人。
Afrikaners belong in Africa. So we don't want to be refugees. We want to be here. We are African. We belong here. The Afrikaners are a specific group with a proud history.
南非荷兰人属于非洲。所以我们不想成为难民。我们想待在这里。我们是非洲人。我们属于这里。南非荷兰人是一个拥有光荣历史的特殊群体。
The history that you may know about Afrikaners is that they invented apartheid, that for nearly half a century, Afrikaners maintained a brutal and violent system of racial segregation in South Africa that denied Black South Africans political and economic power-- the right to vote, the right to own land, to equal housing, education, wages, to move freely, speak freely, and choose where to live, to run businesses.
你可能了解到的关于南非荷兰人的历史是，他们发明了种族隔离制度。近半个世纪以来，南非荷兰人在南非维持了一套残酷而暴力的种族隔离系统，剥夺了南非黑人的政治和经济权力——投票权、土地所有权、平等住房权、教育权、工资权、自由行动权、自由言论权、居住选择权以及经商权。
Joost is referring to the Afrikaner history before all of that, the mostly Dutch settlers who came to South Africa and became Afrikaners more than three centuries ago, set up farms, fought the British.
尤斯特指的是那之前的南非荷兰人历史，也就是三个多世纪前来到南非并成为南非荷兰人的主要是荷兰移民，他们建立了农场，与英国人作战。
We moved away from British occupation with ox and wagon. And we are farming people. We are people of the open veld. We modernized our language. We did the first heart transplant, and so on. And now all of that's taken away. We have no political say. We have no place.
我们赶着牛车离开了英国的占领区。我们是农耕民族。我们是开阔原野的人民。我们使我们的语言现代化。我们进行了世界上首例心脏移植手术，等等。而现在这一切都被拿走了。我们没有政治话语权。我们无处安身。
When South Africa became a democracy after apartheid in 1994, it was one of the few countries in the world that was trying to build a democracy with lots of different people, different races, religions, with 11 official national languages. The new South Africa branded itself the Rainbow Nation. Rainbowism emphasized unity. And Joost felt the Afrikaner identity was shoved aside and threatened. Afrikaners were expected to be just South African.
1994年种族隔离结束后南非成为民主国家时，它是世界上少数几个试图建立一个包容众多不同种族、宗教、拥有11种官方语言的人民的民主国家之一。新南非给自己打上了“彩虹之国”的标签。“彩虹主义”强调团结。而尤斯特感到南非荷兰人的身份被边缘化并受到了威胁。人们期望南非荷兰人只是“南非人”。
The issue is, with Afrikaners, we're a very small minority in a very large country. Just demographic realities, being such a minority, that we have so little influence politically and economically-- who's going to call the shots? It's always the majority, and minorities gets trampled on.
问题在于，对于南非荷兰人来说，我们是一个非常庞大国家里的一个极少数群体。仅仅是人口现实，作为一个如此小的少数族裔，我们在政治和经济上几乎没有影响力——谁说了算？总是多数派，而少数派会被践踏。
A word on the trampling of white South Africans-- they own nearly three times the farmland of Black South Africans and hold more than 60% of the top corporate jobs in South Africa, while being around 7% of the population. There was no massive wealth or land redistribution after apartheid fell. Instead, the government has adopted various policies to try to rectify vast racial imbalances in employment, education, resources, everything over time, bit by bit.
关于南非白人被践踏的一点说明——他们拥有的农田几乎是南非黑人的三倍，在南非占据了超过60%的高管职位，而他们的人口仅占总人口的7%左右。种族隔离结束后，并没有发生大规模的财富或土地再分配。相反，政府采取了各种政策，试图随着时间推移，一点一点地纠正就业、教育、资源等方面的巨大种族失衡。
These were various affirmative action type efforts, like requiring companies to diversify their shareholders, and recently, a new land reform law that would allow the government, in rare cases, to take property without compensation. That's the trampling Joost is talking about and President Trump's executive order is talking about. The only problem for Joost with the executive order was that whole refugee bit.
这些是各种形式的平权行动，例如要求公司实现股东多元化，最近还有一项新的土地改革法，允许政府在极少数情况下无偿征用财产。这就是尤斯特所说的，也是特朗普总统行政命令所指的“践踏”。尤斯特对该行政命令唯一的问题就是那个关于“难民”的部分。
And I gathered some of the decision makers in our community, and we decided to immediately react to this. So we had a very, very serious conversation. We understood it as a watershed moment. And we said, well, we're going to give a very simple message that we will put on social media, hoping to reach the Trump administration with that. And our message was basically, firstly, thank you. And secondly, we appreciate it.
于是我召集了我们社区的一些决策者，我们决定立即对此做出反应。我们进行了一次非常、非常严肃的谈话。我们理解这是一个转折点。我们说，好吧，我们要发一条非常简单的信息放到社交媒体上，希望能借此传达到特朗普政府。我们的信息基本上是：首先，谢谢；其次，我们很感激。
But then we don't want to be refugees in another man's country. We have a three-word message for President Trump. And that is rather, help us here. And "help us here" became our slogan.
但我们不想成为别人国家的难民。我们要给特朗普总统传达一个三个词的信息。那就是“帮帮我们这里”（help us here）。“帮帮我们这里”成了我们的口号。
The two big Afrikaner advocacy groups in South Africa were on the same page. Thank you. You see us and our plight. And no thank you on that whole refugee part. Help us here. Joost went with the delegation of Afrikaners to America to lobby in DC and New York. And the message seemed to land. They made international headlines. No, thanks. White South Africans turned down Trump's US immigration offer. Afrikaner communities reject Trump's resettlement offer.
南非两大南非荷兰人倡导组织达成了共识：谢谢，你看到了我们和我们的困境。但是对于难民那部分，不用了。帮帮我们这里。尤斯特带着一个南非荷兰人代表团去了美国，在华盛顿和纽约进行游说。信息似乎传达到了。他们登上了国际头条。“不用了，谢谢。南非白人拒绝了特朗普的美国移民提议。南非荷兰人社区拒绝了特朗普的安置提议。”
We were mortified.
我们当时感到非常丢脸。
You were what?
你说什么？
Mortified, mortified, mortified. Because hold on a minute. We don't want President Trump to take this away because we apparently said no, thank you. We don't say no, thank you. We accept.
丢脸，丢脸，丢脸。因为等等，我们要冷静一下。我们不想让特朗普总统把这个机会收回，因为我们表现得好像说了“不用了，谢谢”。我们没有说“不用了，谢谢”。我们接受。
Sam Busa fuming from her home on the eastern coast of South Africa, KwaZulu-Natal-- these big Afrikaner membership groups going to America, acting like they're speaking for everyone.
萨姆·布萨在南非东海岸的夸祖鲁-纳塔尔省家中气得发抖——这些大型南非荷兰人会员组织去美国，表现得好像他们代表了所有人一样。
Needless to say, the people that were not their members and did not think that way became very angry. And then they all found me.
不用说，那些不是他们会员、且想法不同的人变得非常愤怒。然后他们都找到了我。
Joost's efforts might have been the end of things, except for Sam popped up. She saw that executive order, and Sam had different ideas for what to do with it. Sam is 60 years old, semi-retired businesswoman, white, constitutionally busy. She is rarely doing one thing at a time.
尤斯特的努力本可能就是结局，除非萨姆出现了。她看到了那份行政命令，萨姆对如何利用它有了不同的想法。萨姆60岁，半退休的女性商人，白人，天生忙碌。她很少同时只做一件事。
I'm going to put the kettle on while I'm talking to you--
我跟你说话的时候要烧点开水——
OK, perfect.
好的，没问题。
--and have a tea break.
——去休息一下喝杯茶。
Wonderful.
太好了。
She told me the story.
她给我讲了这个故事。
There I was, happily getting on with my organic gardening at the beginning of February 2025. And out of the blue came this executive order, to everybody's shock and surprise, let's be honest. So I immediately thought, myself, I'm all for this. But still, the idea of refugee was a bit of a shock.
当时我正在2025年2月初快乐地打理我的有机花园。突然间，行政命令就出来了，老实说，让所有人都感到震惊和意外。所以我立刻想，我完全支持这个。但“难民”这个词确实有点让人震惊。
Did you think, refugees? That's not a word that I would guess you had associated with yourself before.
你当时想，“难民”？这可不是一个我猜你会联想到自己的词。
No. No, no. It was actually a horrifying word. You know what the word refugee conjures up? Is raggedy people that have run across a border that are escaping a war zone and are hiding under a tree, waiting for a helicopter to rescue them. That's what it conjures, doesn't it? And so it was totally foreign to me. And I looked at this, and I thought, wow.
不，不，不。那实际上是一个可怕的词。你知道“难民”这个词会让人联想到什么吗？是衣衫褴褛的人跑过边境，逃离战区，躲在树下等着直升机来营救他们。这才是它联想到的画面，不是吗？所以这对我很陌生。我看着它，想，哇。
The word refugee was totally foreign to Sam, just like it was to Joost. But Sam still felt sure the executive order was intended for her. And she wanted it to be for her. Sam wanted to move to America. She was convinced there was no future for her young adult sons in South Africa, that the country was too dangerous, and that as white men, they'd be discriminated against and unable to succeed. So this seemed like a great opportunity if she could figure it out.
“难民”这个词对萨姆来说完全陌生，正如对尤斯特一样。但萨姆仍然确信行政命令是为她准备的。她也希望它是为她准备的。萨姆想搬到美国。她确信她的年轻儿子在南非没有未来，这个国家太危险了，作为白人男性，他们会受到歧视，无法成功。所以如果她能弄明白的话，这似乎是一个绝佳的机会。
This executive order, like most of the 200-plus executive orders that have come out this year, it's not a detailed document. It's two pages. It's a broad announcement that injustice is happening in South Africa, Afrikaners are the victims, and they're invited to be refugees in America. What it does not say is how this will work, how many people, who qualifies, how to apply. How do these particular people fit within the existing laws that govern the refugee program? How will they get through the vetting process? It leaves all those details to be sorted out at some other time by someone else.
这份行政命令，就像今年出台的200多项行政命令中的大多数一样，不是一份详细的文件。它只有两页。这是一个广泛的公告，称南非正在发生不公正，南非荷兰人是受害者，他们被邀请作为难民来到美国。它没有说这将如何运作，有多少人，谁有资格，如何申请。这些人如何符合现有的管理难民计划的法律？他们如何通过背景审查程序？它把所有这些细节都留给别人以后再去处理。
Sam took it upon herself to be that someone. The first thing to tackle was that word refugee. Sam was not a refugee. Or was she? Could she possibly be one?
萨姆承担起成为那个“别人”的角色。首先要解决的就是“难民”这个词。萨姆不是难民。或者她是吗？她可能成为难民吗？
After 40 years in business, I've got a pretty decent knowledge of legal stuff. So I just went and looked in the obvious places. Like, OK, so who runs refugee programs? OK, so it's PRM. OK. Who else is involved? Oh, USCIS. So I went on their websites and tried to understand the difference between refugees and asylees. But it didn't take me very long. I was quite obsessed.
做了40年生意，我对法律事务有相当不错的了解。所以我只是去看了看显而易见的地方。好吧，谁经营难民计划？好的，是人口、难民和移民局（PRM）。还有谁参与？噢，美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）。所以我去了他们的网站，试图理解难民和庇护申请者之间的区别。这没花我太久时间。我相当痴迷。
A key thing Sam wanted to know-- could she qualify as a refugee if she hadn't fled the country? In all the government websites she went to, the answer seemed pretty straightforward-- no. A refugee is someone who is living, quote, "outside any country of such person's nationality." Refugees are people who flee. Sam was living at home in her home country.
萨姆想知道的关键一点是——如果她没有逃离该国，她能以难民身份获得资格吗？在她访问的所有政府网站上，答案似乎非常直接——不能。难民是居住在“其国籍国之外”的人。难民是那些逃离的人。萨姆住在家里的国家。
But then she found a section of immigration law, 101(a)(42)(B), which allows a refugee to be in country under special circumstances specified by the president. Aha, this is how President Trump could do it. Maybe she could qualify.
但后来她发现了一段移民法，第101(a)(42)(B)条，该条允许难民在总统指定的特殊情况下留在国内。啊哈，这就是特朗普总统可以做到的方式。也许她能获得资格。
It became apparent to me that there are many types of refugee programs and that it wouldn't be a case of expecting South Africans to literally go into FEMA tents or anything like that. It became pretty clear to me that these things can be rather dignified and quite orderly.
我意识到难民计划有很多类型，并不是说要让南非人真正住进联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的帐篷之类的东西。很明显，这些事情可以变得相当体面且井然有序。
This was her first stab at interpreting the language in the executive order, figuring out how she could fit the word refugee legally and comfortably. Next, the executive order uses the words, quote, "unjust racial discrimination." It says it's for the victims of discrimination. Sam was confident her family qualified for that. She says specifically, her young adult sons have been denied or would be denied jobs in South Africa because they're white.
这是她对行政命令中措辞的首次解读，想弄清楚如何才能合法且舒服地套用“难民”这个词。接下来，行政命令使用了“不正当种族歧视”的字眼。它说是为了歧视的受害者。萨姆确信她的家人符合条件。她特别提到，她的年轻儿子因为是白人而在南非被拒绝或将要被拒绝工作。
But if Sam went to the officials who screened refugee applications to America, she wasn't sure discrimination would actually be enough to qualify as a refugee. She read the main law governing US immigration, the Immigration and Nationality Act. And--
但如果萨姆去找那些筛选来美难民申请的官员，她不确定“歧视”是否足以获得难民资格。她读了管理美国移民的主要法律，《移民与国籍法》。而且——
The word discrimination's not used. In dealing with refugees around the world, they never used the word discrimination. Yet, President Trump used the word discrimination. Quite possibly, the word discrimination in the executive order probably wasn't his best choice of word. I think he probably meant to say persecution. Because persecution is required.
“歧视”这个词没有被用到。在处理世界各地的难民时，他们从来不用“歧视”这个词。然而，特朗普总统却用了“歧视”这个词。很有可能，行政命令中的“歧视”一词可能不是他最好的用词。我想他大概想说的是“迫害”。因为必须要有“迫害”才行。
Another puzzle for Sam to figure out. Meanwhile--
萨姆要解决的另一个谜题。与此同时——
I decided to put up a little website, questions and answers. And then whatever my findings are, let me share those with my fellow citizens. OK. I came across the word Amerikaners, which I thought was cute as anything.
我决定建立一个小网站，放上问答。然后，我有什么发现，就与我的同胞分享。好了。我偶然发现了“Amerikaners”这个词，我觉得它可爱极了。
Amerikaners is Afrikaans for Americans. She registered the domain and set up a Facebook page. This became a hub for other white South Africans who'd heard about the executive order.
“Amerikaners”是南非荷兰语中“美国人”的意思。她注册了域名并建立了一个Facebook页面。这成为了其他听说过行政命令的南非白人的中心。
So we started disseminating what we, in our personal capacity, had investigated. And obviously, there were lots of I don't knows that went with all of that. So I don't want to give anybody the opinion that somehow we knew everything.
所以我们开始传播我们以个人身份调查到的东西。显然，所有这一切都伴随着很多“不知道”。所以我不想给任何人一种我们什么都知道的感觉。
What were a lot of the repeat questions or most common questions?
重复出现的问题或最常见的问题有哪些？
Well, one of the most difficult ones was, they say Afrikaners. Now, in South Africa-- you're American. You don't understand the nuance of the cultures in South Africa. So half of the white population is English speaking. So all of the folks, like myself, that's of British descent was thinking, oh, no. They're just going to take the Afrikaners and not me, the Englishman.
嗯，最难的问题之一是，他们说是“南非荷兰人”（Afrikaners）。在南非——你是美国人，你不了解南非文化的细微差别。一半的白人人口是说英语的。所以所有像我这样有英国血统的人都在想：“噢，不。他们只会接收南非荷兰人，而不会接收我这个英国人。”
You're not Afrikaner?
你不是南非荷兰人？
Yeah. No, I'm not an Afrikaner.
是的。不，我不是南非荷兰人。
Pause. This was surprising to me. Sam was running a website for people interested in Trump's offer to Afrikaners. Afrikaners are generally descended from Dutch settlers, speak Afrikaans as their first language. White South Africans who are not Afrikaners-- generally English ancestry. We were 20 minutes into talking. It hadn't actually occurred to me to ask if she indeed was Afrikaner. She's not.
暂停。这让我感到意外。萨姆在为一个对特朗普给南非荷兰人提议感兴趣的人运作一个网站。南非荷兰人通常是荷兰移民的后裔，以南非荷兰语为第一语言。非南非荷兰人的南非白人——通常有英国血统。我们谈了20分钟。我竟然没想过问她到底是不是南非荷兰人。她不是。
But this was another spot where the word in the executive order did not precisely fit Sam until Sam figured out how it could fit.
但这是行政命令中的词并不完全适合萨姆的另一个地方，直到萨姆想出了如何让它契合的方法。
But the truth is, these groups have mixed, intermingled across hundreds of years. So to prove one person is an Afrikaner and the other doesn't have any Afrikaner is almost impossible without genealogies for everybody. So we did make a deduction. I'm sure, as an English person, you'll be included. But we always had to put a disclaimer on that because we just don't know, what does an American think the word Afrikaner means?
但事实是，这些群体在几百年里已经混合、交融了。所以要证明一个人是南非荷兰人，而另一个人没有任何南非荷兰人血统，如果没有所有人的族谱，几乎是不可能的。所以我们做了一个推论。我相信，作为一个英国人，你会包括在内。但我们总是必须对此加上免责声明，因为我们根本不知道，美国人认为“南非荷兰人”这个词意味着什么？
So you thought, OK, they might mean only Afrikaners, meaning strictly Afrikaner background ancestry, speaks Afrikaans. They might mean somebody who lives on a farm. They might just mean white people in South Africa.
所以你认为，好吧，他们可能只指南非荷兰人，意思是严格的南非荷兰人血统，讲南非荷兰语。他们可能指住在农场里的人。他们可能只是指在南非的白人。
Correct. So I cautiously told everybody that it was my opinion that it included all South Africans, English and Afrikaans.
正确。所以我谨慎地告诉所有人，我认为它包括所有南非人，无论是英国人还是南非荷兰人。
All white South Africans.
所有南非白人。
But I was only 95% sure.
但我只有95%的把握。
Almost everyone who came to the Amerikaners Facebook page had the same question Sam had. Do I qualify to go to the US under this executive order? Here's a comment. "Not a funny or rude question, just want to know, what criteria is acceptable candidate? How bad does your experience need to be?"
几乎每个来到“Amerikaners” Facebook页面的人都有和萨姆一样的问题。我有资格根据这个行政命令去美国吗？这里有一条评论。“这不是一个搞笑或粗鲁的问题，只是想知道，什么标准才算是可接受的候选人？你的经历需要多糟糕？”
Another-- "How will the USA decide if I'm suitable? I'm white, Afrikaans, male, hardworking with strong Christian beliefs, in a country where I'm prosecuted for my skin color, my language, my beliefs. Does that make me, quote, 'suitable,' or must I first be shot and stabbed?" There were other questions too.
另一个——“美国将如何决定我是否合适？我是白人，南非荷兰语，男性，勤劳，有坚定的基督教信仰，在一个因我的肤色、语言、信仰而迫害我的国家。这让我变得‘合适’吗？还是说我必须先被枪杀和捅伤？”还有其他问题。
I'm 56. Aren't I too old? Or am I allowed to bring my dogs? And is it just for farmers? Because a lot of people were talking about the farmers all the time. President Trump's also mentioned a lot about farmers. What about if I'm not--
我56岁了。我太老了吗？或者我可以带上我的狗吗？这只是给农民的吗？因为很多人一直在谈论农民。特朗普总统也多次提到了农民。如果我不是——
What are the answers?
答案是什么？
--a farmer? OK. So myself and one of the volunteers did is, we analyzed every single word that had been said by the president and the State Department beyond the executive order, so the fact sheet that was put out as well as the FAQs that were put out. But what we were saying to people is, look, a refugee program in general does not discriminate whether you're 90 or you're 2. If you're in peril, refugee programs are accepting of any human being in peril.
——农民呢？好的。我和志愿者所做的是，我们分析了总统和国务院在行政命令之外说的每一个字，也就是发布的事实清单以及发布的常见问题解答。但我们告诉人们的是，看，难民计划通常不会歧视你是90岁还是2岁。如果你处于危险之中，难民计划是接受任何处于危险中的人类的。
So that sort of deduction, we were able to make and answer lots of questions. Can you bring your dogs? No. Well, you can, but you'll do that privately, out of your own pocket. But the refugee program is not inviting your pets.
所以这种推论，我们能够做出并回答很多问题。你能带你的狗吗？不能。嗯，你可以，但你得自掏腰包私人处理。但难民计划不欢迎你的宠物。
This is the level of detail Sam was helping people to think through. One problem she still had to solve-- the question of persecution. To qualify as a refugee, one must be able to articulate a past experience of persecution or fear of future persecution.
这就是萨姆帮助人们理清细节的水平。她仍然需要解决的一个问题——关于“迫害”的问题。要获得难民资格，一个人必须能够表达过去遭受迫害的经历或对未来迫害的恐惧。
Yeah. Well, I've had some events in my life which I would struggle to classify as persecution. So my past persecution records are somewhat scant. They barely make the persecution grade, OK? So they would rise to severe discrimination. So look, I've been held at gunpoint with my baby in my arms. But I can't say that that's persecution. What I can say is that's just terrible crime.
是的。嗯，我的生活中发生过一些我难以归类为迫害的事情。所以我的过去迫害记录有点贫乏。它们勉强达到迫害等级，好吧？它们会上升到严重歧视。所以，你看，我曾被人用枪指着，怀里还抱着婴儿。但我不能说那是迫害。我只能说那只是可怕的犯罪。
South Africa does have terrible crime, crime that is experienced by every demographic group. But Sam looked at the precise definition.
南非确实有可怕的犯罪，这是每个群体都会经历的犯罪。但萨姆查看了精确的定义。
You can either talk about something that's happened to you that was persecution, or you can talk about-- so it's and/or-- or you can talk about your fear of future persecution.
你可以谈论你身上发生的迫害事件，或者你可以谈论——所以是“和/或”——或者你可以谈论你对未来迫害的恐惧。
This became a big topic in the Amerikaners group, what counts as future persecution. In the various group chats and on the Facebook page, there was one video that got passed around often as potential evidence. It's a video of a Black politician from a minority party in South Africa leading a chant called kill the Boer at a political rally. Boer is farmers in Afrikaans. Kill the Boer is an old anti-apartheid chant. Afrikaner groups say it's clearly intended incite violence. And the lyrics are pretty stark. Kill the Boer, the farmer.
这成了“Amerikaners”群组里的一个大话题，什么算作未来的迫害。在各种群聊和Facebook页面上，有一个视频经常作为潜在证据被转发。这是一个南非少数党黑人政客在政治集会上领导高呼名为《杀掉布尔人》（Kill the Boer）口号的视频。“布尔人”在南非荷兰语中是农民的意思。《杀掉布尔人》是一首古老的反种族隔离歌曲。南非荷兰人团体说，它显然旨在煽动暴力。歌词非常刺耳：杀掉布尔人，那个农民。
There have been several court cases about the use of the song over the years. Most recently, in an appeal, the judge at the constitutional court wrote that a reasonably well-informed person would understand that the politician was using a historic struggle song as a provocative way to advance a political agenda. It was a form of political speech and therefore protected under the country's freedom of speech laws. Elon Musk posted the video on X. Musk, South African born, wrote, quote, "They are openly pushing for a genocide of white people in South Africa."
多年来，关于这首歌的使用有过几起法庭案件。最近一次在上诉中，宪法法院的法官写道，一个理性的、消息灵通的人会明白，这位政客是在使用一首历史斗争歌曲作为推进政治议程的挑衅性方式。这是一种政治言论形式，因此受到国家言论自由法的保护。埃隆·马斯克在X上发布了这段视频。出生于南非的马斯克写道：“他们公开推动在南非对白人进行种族灭绝。”
So my fear of future persecution and future violence is way greater than my history. My fear of future persecution is basically being skinned alive in a genocide. You've got government ministers and the constitutional court endor-- well, no endorsing, but allowing, saying that they're entitled to call for the death of white people in South Africa. And then you've got the government that is completely silent on them calling for the death of white South Africans. So if that's not persecution, I don't know what is.
所以，我对未来迫害和未来暴力的恐惧远大于我的历史。我对未来迫害的恐惧基本上是会被种族灭绝中活生生剥皮。你有政府部长和宪法法院背书——嗯，不，不是背书，但允许，说是他们有权呼吁在南非杀死白人。然后你的政府对他们呼吁杀死南非白人保持完全沉默。如果那不是迫害，我不知道什么才是。
Sam had made it through each tricky word in the executive order-- refugee, Afrikaner, discrimination. She'd interpreted the order and translated it and figured out how it would work, how it was legal, and who could qualify-- her and all the other like-minded people she'd organized into a group through her website.
萨姆已经理清了行政命令中每一个棘手的词——难民、南非荷兰人、歧视。她解读并翻译了该命令，并弄清楚了它将如何运作，它是如何合法的，以及谁能获得资格——她和她通过网站组织成一个群体的所有志同道合的人。
Six weeks after the executive order came out, Sam wrote her own message to President Trump. Joost Strydom's communiqué had a polite, three-point summary. Sam's did too. But her message was very different. Sam says hers was signed by 27,000 people in two weeks.
行政命令出台六周后，萨姆写了她自己给特朗普总统的信息。尤斯特·斯特里多姆的公报有一个礼貌的三点摘要。萨姆的也有。但她的信息非常不同。萨姆说她的信息在两周内获得了27000人的签名。
So the memorandum said three things. Thank you. We appreciate what you've done by reaching out and extending this offer. Number 2, we accept your offer. And number 3, we will come to contribute, not to drain.
备忘录说了三件事。第一，谢谢。感谢你伸出援手并发出邀请。第二，我们接受你的提议。第三，我们会来贡献，而不是消耗。
The Amerikaners delivered their memorandum to the US embassy in Pretoria. And Sam posted a photo to the Facebook page. She wrote, "We've gathered. We've organized. We've collaborated. We've spoken. We've succeeded."
“Amerikaners”将他们的备忘录送到了美国驻比勒陀利亚大使馆。萨姆把照片发到了Facebook页面上。她写道：“我们聚集了。我们组织了。我们合作了。我们发声了。我们成功了。”
The first group of white South Africans granted refugee status by the Trump administration arrived in the US Monday.
第一批被特朗普政府授予难民身份的南非白人周一抵达美国。
The United States has welcomed around 50 white South Africans following President Trump's--
美国欢迎了约50名南非白人，紧随特朗普总统的——
May 12, 2025-- 59 white South Africans. Sam Busa was not one of them. She was watching from South Africa. While Sam was organizing Amerikaners, the US government had been rapidly putting together a small group of South African refugees, bringing them over on a private chartered plane to Dulles Airport. At Dulles, they stood in a loosely arranged line, holding small American flags, their children in pajamas, smiling, unsure which camera to look at as they were personally welcomed by the deputy secretaries of both the US State Department and the Department of Homeland Security.
2025年5月12日——59名南非白人。萨姆·布萨不在其中。她正在南非注视着。当萨姆在组织“Amerikaners”时，美国政府一直在迅速组建一个小型的南非难民群体，通过一架私人包机把他们接到杜勒斯机场。在杜勒斯，他们排成松散的一队，拿着美国小国旗，孩子穿着睡衣，微笑着，不确定该看哪台摄像机，因为他们受到了美国国务院和国土安全部副部长的亲自欢迎。
Welcome. Welcome to the United States of America.
欢迎。欢迎来到美利坚合众国。
Thank you, sir.
谢谢，长官。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It makes me so happy to see you with our flag in your hands. And that flag symbolizes liberty for so many of us. I want you all to know that you are really welcome here and that we respect what you have had to deal with these last few years. We respect the long tradition of your people and what you have accomplished over the years. And I am sure that you will be successful.
看到你们手里拿着我们的国旗，我感到非常高兴。那面旗帜象征着我们许多人的自由。我想让你们知道，你们在这里真的很受欢迎，我们尊重你们过去几年不得不面对的一切。我们尊重你们人民的长久传统以及你们多年来取得的成就。我相信你们会成功的。
Everybody within DHS, we've been so excited to be able to get you guys here. I was tracking your flight, 12 hours that you were-- last night. I'm like, oh my god. So thank you for just the patience of being able to get here. We're so grateful. I think Chris and I both just wanted to come and make sure that we greet you guys, we meet you, give our contact information to you. And if there's anything that we could do--
国土安全部里的每个人都非常兴奋能把你们带到这里。我一直在追踪你们的飞行，昨晚你们飞了12个小时。我心想，天哪。所以感谢你们能够来到这里的耐心。我们非常感激。我想克里斯和我只是想亲自来确保我们欢迎你们，见到你们，给你们我们的联系信息。如果有什么我们能做的——
I have looked at the photos of this press conference so many times, zoomed in on every detail, just trying to make my brain take in this picture, this photo op and everything that it means about America and about South Africa. Those two countries have always played off each other in my mind. My parents grew up in South Africa. I grew up in America watching South Africa. It's where our family was. And South Africa has always been a symbol.
我看了无数次这张新闻发布会的照片，放大了每一个细节，只是试图让我的大脑接收这个画面，这个拍照的机会以及它关于美国和南非所意味着的一切。这两个国家在我的脑海里总是互为镜像。我的父母在南非长大。我在美国看着南非长大。那是我们家所在的地方。南非一直是一个象征。
In my lifetime, it was a global pariah, boycotted by everyone. And then apartheid fell, and South Africa became a model of justice and reconciliation. American leaders tripped over themselves to celebrate the new South Africa, practically deified Nelson Mandela, photos of President Clinton applauding as Mandela and then-President de Klerk shook hands and Clinton, quote, "thrilled at the peaceful election process and national unity," photos of Mandela winning the Congressional Gold Medal, Newt Gingrich on one side, President Clinton on the other.
在我有生之年，它是一个全球贱民，遭到所有人的抵制。然后种族隔离制度倒台，南非成为正义与和解的典范。美国领导人争相庆祝新南非，几乎将纳尔逊·曼德拉神圣化，克林顿总统鼓掌的照片中，曼德拉和当时的德克勒克总统握手，克林顿称对“和平的选举进程和民族团结感到激动”，曼德拉赢得国会金质奖章的照片，纽特·金里奇在一侧，克林顿总统在另一侧。
America was eager to share in the symbolism of this new multiracial democracy because it added some nice shine to our own. Their story was our story and their redemption ours. Their success was ours too. Now, these photos of Afrikaner refugees in the Dulles Airport, this is a new kind of symbolism, a new way for America to use South Africa to say something about ourselves.
美国渴望分享这个多种族民主国家的象征意义，因为它为我们自己的国家增添了一些光彩。他们的故事就是我们的故事，他们的救赎也是我们的救赎。他们的成功也是我们的成功。现在，这些在杜勒斯机场拍摄的南非荷兰人难民照片，这是一种新的象征意义，美国使用南非来表达关于我们自己的一些东西的新方式。
In these photos, South Africa is not an inspiring symbol of multiracial democracy anymore. That story is over. The photos are like a reset. South Africa is a cautionary tale. It's a DEI nation, a place where white people can no longer be safe, where the tables have turned, where they've gone too far. This is where efforts toward equality lead us. A rainbow nation only ends in disaster. And the photo op communicates something else too. It says, look, this is our new refugee policy.
在这些照片中，南非不再是多种族民主的激励象征了。那个故事结束了。照片就像一次重置。南非是一个警示故事。这是一个多元、平等和包容（DEI）的国家，一个白人不再安全的地方，风水轮流转，他们走得太远了。这就是朝着平等努力的终点。彩虹之国只会以灾难告终。而拍照的机会也传达了别的东西。它在说：“看，这是我们的新难民政策。”
Well, because what's happening in South Africa fits the textbook definition of why the refugee program was created.
嗯，因为发生在南非的事情符合难民计划创建的教科书定义。
Stephen Miller, presidential advisor, seems to be the guy coming up with our immigration policy. The Trump administration suspended refugee admissions to the United States. It was one of the president's first executive orders on his first day in office. Refugees waiting in camps all over the world, sometimes for generations, were cut off. Most refugees wait years for the chance to be vetted to possibly get a chance to come to the United States. These South Africans arrived in three months.
总统顾问斯蒂芬·米勒似乎是制定我们移民政策的人。特朗普政府暂停了难民对美国的入境。这是总统上任第一天签署的第一批行政命令之一。全世界难民营里等待的难民，有时长达几代人，都被切断了。大多数难民等待多年才有机会接受审查，以获得可能来美国的机会。这些南非人在三个月内就到了。
The refugee program is not intended as a solution for global poverty. And historically, it has been used that way.
难民计划并不是为了解决全球贫困问题。从历史上看，它也不是那样使用的。
This is not true. For instance, 12,000 refugees had already been approved to resettle in America when the Afrikaners arrived. They were approved, meaning they'd been through the security clearance, the health check, background check, interviews, and were arranging their travel to the US. Some of them already had flights booked.
这不是真的。例如，在南非荷兰人到达时，已经有12,000名难民获准重新安置到美国。他们获准，意味着他们已经通过了安全审查、健康检查、背景调查、面试，并正在安排前往美国的行程。他们中有些人已经预订了机票。
Those 12,000 people were approved not because they were fleeing poverty. They were fleeing war, religious persecution, political persecution, Congolese families who fled to Rwanda after their neighbors were killed, Rohingya from Myanmar who were fleeing kidnappings, rape, and genocide, some Afghans who supported US troops in America's war effort. Those people, Miller is saying, are not the textbook refugees. These are.
那12,000人获准不是因为他们逃离贫困。他们是在逃离战争、宗教迫害、政治迫害，比如在邻居被杀后逃往卢旺达的刚果家庭，比如逃离绑架、强奸和种族灭绝的缅甸罗兴亚人，比如支持美国在美军战争努力的一些阿富汗人。米勒说，那些人不是教科书上的难民。而这些人是。
After the photo op, back in May, two different schools of thought emerged about what was going to happen next. This is a fancy way of saying Sam and I disagreed. We are the schools of thought. I figured, after seeing those photos and videos of the new South African refugees, I figured, that's probably it for the whole alleged refugee program. It's pretty effective symbolism. I think they got what they wanted. The Trump administration has a lot of other goals to pursue. They're not likely going to bother building a whole program to bring over more people like Sam.
五月拍照活动之后，关于接下来会发生什么出现了两种不同的看法。这是一种委婉的说法，萨姆和我意见不合。我们就是那两种看法。我想，在看到那些关于新南非难民的照片和视频后，我认为，整个所谓的难民计划大概就到此为止了。这是一种非常有效的象征。我想他们得到了他们想要的。特朗普政府还有很多其他目标要追求。他们不太可能费心建立一个完整的项目来带更多像萨姆那样的人过来。
Sam, back in South Africa, had gotten in her application for resettlement to the US and was waiting with her thousands of Amerikaners. And she had a different thought.
萨姆在南非，已经提交了重新安置到美国的申请，并和她成千上万的“Amerikaners”一起等待。她有不同的想法。
I have absolutely no doubt.
我绝对不怀疑。
Sam says she'd read everything everyone was saying, everything every person in the administration, adjacent to the administration--
萨姆说她读了每个人所说的所有内容，政府里的每一个人，政府周边的人——
They're all very intent on, OK, well, this is just the pilot project. We're going to ramp things up now. I have no doubt that that's where it's going.
他们都很专注于，好吧，这只是试点项目。我们要开始扩大规模了。我毫不怀疑那是它发展的方向。
She had no doubt. I had some doubt. One of us was right.
她毫不怀疑。我有一些怀疑。我们中有一个是对的。
Chana Joffe-Walt. Coming up, secret moving companies and a joke about cars-- that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特。接下来，秘密搬家公司和一个关于汽车的笑话——一会儿后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- winners, people who decide "I can make this happen" as the first step to making it happen. If you're just tuning in, we're in the middle of a Chana Joffe-Walt story about Amerikaners, white South Africans who want to come to the United States as refugees. Where we left off-- the United States had brought over a small group of 59 of them. And back in South Africa, Sam Busa had organized thousands of others who were waiting, hoping the United States was about to ramp up a big program for them. Here's Chana.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——赢家，那些决定“我能实现这一点”作为实现它的第一步的人。如果你刚收听，我们正处于查娜·乔菲-沃尔特关于“Amerikaners”的故事中，那些想要作为难民来美国的南非白人。我们停下的地方——美国带了59个他们的小团体过来。而在南非，萨姆·布萨组织了数千名等待的人，希望美国即将为他们扩大规模。请听查娜的报道。
From the moment the 59 South Africans landed in the US, Sam's life was transformed. She was inundated with phone calls, emails.
从那59名南非人登陆美国的那一刻起，萨姆的生活就改变了。她被电话和电子邮件淹没了。
[SIGHS] I'm working 20-hour days, so I'm frazzled. So I'll try and focus.
[叹气] 我每天工作20个小时，所以我精疲力竭。所以我得努力专注。
Everyone who had applied but had not been included in that first small group that went to America wanted to know what this meant. Would they get a call soon? Had Amerikaners heard anything? Reporters wanted to know, what is Amerikaners? How many are you? Who are you? And Americans who saw the news on X or Ben Shapiro or Megyn Kelly wanted to send their support.
所有申请但没有被包括在第一批去美国的小团体中的人都想知道这意味着什么。他们会很快接到电话吗？“Amerikaners”听到什么消息了吗？记者们想知道，“Amerikaners”是什么？你们有多少人？你们是谁？而那些在X或本·夏皮罗或梅根·凯利那里看到新闻的美国人想表达他们的支持。
We've actually had a fantastically loving response from America. In truth, I can't tell you how many hundreds and hundreds of Americans have reached out to us in our little group by email, on our X feeds, all over the place, coming forward, giving the most unbelievable testimony of how excited they are to have us there, and people offering help and-- not money, no, not at all. Nobody's exchanged a cent.
我们实际上收到了来自美国的非常热烈的回应。老实说，我无法告诉你成百上千的美国人是如何通过电子邮件、在我们的X动态上、到处都联系我们，站出来，提供最难以置信的证词，说他们有多兴奋能让我们去那里，人们提供帮助——不是钱，不，完全不是。没有人交换过一分钱。
And tell me about what are people saying. And who are they?
告诉我人们在说什么。他们是谁？
A lot of people just saying, hey, I'm in Alabama, or I'm in Utah , or whatever. I've got a farm here, and I'd be happy to-- I've got a cottage. If somebody wants to stay here for two months, I can give two months accommodation. Or there are people saying, hey, I've got a lot of contacts in business, or I'm involved with the church or whatever. Whoever's coming to Florida, put them in touch with me. I've got lots of contacts. I can probably hook them up.
很多人只是说：“嘿，我在阿拉巴马，或者在犹他州，无论在哪里。我这里有个农场，如果有人愿意住两个月，我很乐意——我有一个小屋。我可以提供两个月的住宿。”或者有人说：“嘿，我在生意上有很多联系人，或者我参与教会等等。谁要来佛罗里达，让他们和我联系。我有很多联系人。我可能可以帮他们牵线搭桥。”
Sam responds to each person who reaches out and tells them, we don't have anyone for you yet, but as soon as they ramp up this program, we'll be in touch. Thank you so much.
萨姆回复了每一个联系她的人，告诉他们，我们还没有人为你们准备好，但一旦他们扩大了这个项目的规模，我们就会联系。非常感谢。
We are so excited to join your society, I can't explain.
我们太兴奋能加入你们的社会了，我无法解释。
And then she puts their name, the state they're from, and contact information into a spreadsheet for the future. Sam said there were 70,000 people interested in going to America.
然后她把他们的名字、他们所在的州和联系信息放在电子表格里备用。萨姆说有70,000人对去美国感兴趣。
Oh, yeah. No, we're all coming over. No, we'll see you soon--
噢，是的。不，我们都要过来。不，很快会见到你们——
Wow.
哇。
--on our way, around the corner.
——在路上，就在拐角处。
Maybe. But in the meantime, they were still living in South Africa. And their fellow countrymen also saw all the photos from Washington and the press conferences from the White House about persecution, targeting, and murder of white South Africans. South Africans were not, as a whole, happy about this. The government spent weeks repeating, there is no persecution. Crime in South Africa affects everyone, irrespective of race. South African President Cyril Ramaphosa called the South Africans who left for the US cowards--
也许吧。但与此同时，他们仍然住在南非。他们的同胞也看到了所有来自华盛顿的照片以及白宫关于迫害、针对和谋杀南非白人的新闻发布会。南非人总的来说对此并不高兴。政府花了数周时间重复说，没有迫害。南非的犯罪影响每个人，不分种族。南非总统西里尔·拉马福萨称那些去美国的南非人是懦夫——
When you run away, you're a coward. And that's a real cowardly act.
当你逃跑时，你就是个懦夫。那是非常懦弱的行为。
--which made news.
——这上了新闻。
Ramaphosa claimed these individuals were unwilling to support the country's efforts to correct historic inequities left by apartheid.
拉马福萨声称这些人不愿意支持国家纠正种族隔离遗留的历史不平等的努力。
A populist political party made a show of filing a criminal complaint against one of the Afrikaner lobbying groups, calling them treasonous for spreading lies to the United States in order to influence President Trump. Reactions from regular South Africans ranged from confusion, like this Afrikaner interviewed by Reuters--
一个民粹主义政党展示了对南非荷兰人游说团体之一提出刑事控诉，称他们向美国传播谎言以影响特朗普总统是叛国罪。普通南非人的反应从困惑开始，比如路透社采访的这位南非荷兰人——
Why would you want to go? People carry on like normal. And what are you going to do over there?
你为什么要走？人们生活得像正常人一样。你到那边去做什么？
--to mockery. Here's a white comedian on TikTok talking to a Black comedian.
——到嘲笑。这是一个TikTok上的白人喜剧演员和一个黑人喜剧演员对话。
I turned on the TV the other night, and I hear from Donald Trump and Elon Musk that you've been planning a genocide.
前几天晚上我打开电视，听到唐纳德·特朗普和埃隆·马斯克说你们一直在计划种族灭绝。
The Black comedian sitting next to him says, oh, yeah, we're killing every day.
坐在他旁边的黑人喜剧演员说，噢，是的，我们每天都在杀人。
I was actually playing padel today. And I thought to myself, goodness gracious, we are not killing fast enough.
我今天实际上在打板球。我心想，天哪，我们杀人的速度还不够快。
And there were lots of angry South Africans on social media.
社交媒体上有很多愤怒的南非人。
You are not refugees. You're not brave. You're not victims. You're scared of a world where you don't get to be in charge. And that makes the rest of the Afrikaans community cringe.
你们不是难民。你们不勇敢。你们不是受害者。你们只是害怕一个你们不再掌权的世界。这让其余的南非荷兰人社区感到尴尬。
Trevor Noah-- South Africa's own-- on his podcast, asked his friend Eugene Khoza about it.
特雷弗·诺亚——南非自己的——在他的播客上问了他的朋友尤金·科扎关于这件事。
When was the first time you ever heard about white genocide in South Africa?
你第一次听说南非有针对白人的种族灭绝是什么时候？
It was this year. It was when everyone caught on to it. I almost felt like I was living in another country. Because I looked outside, and I was like--
是今年。是当每个人都发现它的时候。我几乎感觉自己住在另一个国家。因为我看向外面，心想——
That's crazy.
那太疯狂了。
--where is this thing happening? And I checked on my neighbor. She was fine.
——这件事在哪发生？我去看了我的邻居。她很好。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The arrival of white South Africans in America was enough of a national spectacle, an in-joke, that some advertisers got in on it-- for instance, a car commercial where a bunch of white men in Jeeps pull up outside a Black man's house, wake him up, revving their engines. The man comes out of his house in his robe, saying, what's going on? And the white men yell, you haven't heard?
南非白人抵达美国是一个足够大的国家奇观，一个内部笑话，以至于一些广告商也参与其中——例如一个汽车广告，一群白人男子开着吉普车停在一个黑人房子的外面，吵醒他，轰着引擎。那人穿着睡袍从房子里出来，说：“怎么了？”然后白人男子大喊：“你还没听说吗？”
You haven't heard? We've got "rev-jou-jeep" status, baby.
你还没听说吗？我们得到了“rev-jou-jeep”身份，宝贝。
[HONKING]
[喇叭声]
They rev the engines more. The Black man walks over to one of them.
他们更多地轰着引擎。黑人男子向其中一个人走去。
Can I give it a go?
我可以试一试吗？
No. Apparently, it's just for us.
不。显然，这只是给我们的。
These jokes and comments, they were coming from people who all went through something together not that long ago-- the end of apartheid, the transition to democracy, a process that was painstakingly designed to happen peacefully, to take white South Africans' worries into account and to keep them in the fold. Nobody gave up land or wealth. Nobody tore down institutions. So much of that went unchanged.
这些笑话和评论，来自不久前一起经历过某事的人——种族隔离结束，民主转型，这个过程被精心设计以和平方式进行，考虑到南非白人的担忧并让他们留在这个大家庭里。没有人放弃土地或财富。没有人拆毁机构。很多东西都没有改变。
On Trevor Noah's podcast, his friend, comedian Eugene Khoza, says the white refugee thing has him thinking back to that time after apartheid fell and how quickly Black South Africans were asked to move to reconciliation while white South Africans still held so much power over day-to-day life.
在特雷弗·诺亚的播客上，他的朋友，喜剧演员尤金·科扎说，白人难民的事情让他想起种族隔离倒台后的那段时间，以及南非黑人被要求迅速进入和解，而南非白人在日常生活中仍然掌握着如此多的权力。
We had to make nice very, very quickly. As soon as that ended, you had to be nice to the school governing body for your child to enter that school. You had to be nice to show that you're not like that kind of a crime in an estate, in a housing community. We had to be nice. So the ones that could played nice to be in those communities. The ones that couldn't afford played nice to work in those communities. I think South Africa became a poster child for diplomacy. We almost had to, as a country, put our best foot forward.
我们必须非常、非常迅速地和解。一旦结束，你就必须对学校管理机构好，让你的孩子进入那所学校。你必须表现得好，以显示你在庄园、社区里不是那种犯罪类型。我们必须表现得好。所以能做到的人表现得好以进入那些社区。不能做到的人表现得好以在那些社区工作。我认为南非成了外交的海报。我们几乎必须作为一个国家，展现出最好的一面。
Everyone moves forward. That was the whole agreement of post-apartheid South Africa. The white people, who used to have all the power and now only had some of the power, would accept things and move forward. And Black South Africans, who used to have no power and now had a little more, would agree to forgive the architects of apartheid and just move forward. Nobody looks back. Nobody complains. We all just get on with building the country, together. The white South Africans who wanted to be refugees in America, they were breaking that agreement.
每个人都在前进。这就是后种族隔离南非的整个协议。曾经拥有所有权力现在只有一些权力的白人，将接受一切并前进。而曾经没有权力现在有了更多一点权力的南非黑人，将同意宽恕种族隔离的建筑师并前进。没有人回头。没有人抱怨。我们都在一起建设国家。那些想成为美国难民的南非白人，他们正在打破这个协议。
We're a very, very hated class in South Africa right now-- hated, hated, hated.
我们现在是南非一个非常、非常受憎恨的阶层——受憎恨，受憎恨，受憎恨。
Sam continued what she'd been doing-- managing the Amerikaners site, preparing people, responding to questions. But Amerikaners were a thing now for everyone, from social media to moving companies-- and not a positive thing.
萨姆继续做她一直在做的事情——管理“Amerikaners”网站，准备人员，回答问题。但“Amerikaners”现在对每个人来说都是一回事，从社交媒体到搬家公司——而且不是一件积极的事情。
OK. So people are going to want to send some boxes with granny's keepsakes in it and whatever. They might leave their furniture behind. But most families will want to take a box or two. So I set out to speak to all the removals companies that can do international removals to America in South Africa. Strangely enough, which actually shocked me, quite a few of them said, oh, I don't want anything to do with you refugees, put the phone down in my ear. And--
好的。所以人们会想寄一些装着奶奶纪念品之类的盒子。他们可能会把家具留下。但大多数家庭会想带一两个盒子。所以我去和南非所有能做去美国国际搬运的搬运公司谈了。奇怪的是，这让我很震惊，相当多的人说：“噢，我不想和你们这些难民有任何关系。”然后挂断了电话。而且——
Wait. Sam, had you experienced that before? Was that shocking to you?
等等。萨姆，你以前经历过那个吗？这对你来说很震惊吗？
Totally, yeah. It's almost like we're second-class citizens now or something like that or that they don't want to be seen by the people who are staying to be supportive of the refugee program. And those that wanted to help also didn't want their logos anywhere on publicly because they thought they would be subject to attack. So I couldn't advertise somebody's company on my website and say, hey, these guys will offer a good deal, and show a banner with their logo on it.
完全是，是的。简直就像我们现在是二等公民一样，或者他们不想被留下的人看到支持难民计划。而那些想帮忙的人也不想把他们的标志放在公开的地方，因为他们认为会受到攻击。所以我不能在我的网站上做某人的公司广告并说：“嘿，这些人会提供一个好的交易，”并展示一个带有他们标志的横幅。
So she figured out a workaround. On her website, Sam put a tab called Packing Up in SA.
所以她想出了一个变通办法。在她的网站上，萨姆放了一个叫“在南非打包”（Packing Up in SA）的标签。
On the righthand side of that page, I have a little form so you can put your info in as a refugee. And then there is secret people that like the refugees that are willing to help them in the background that get an email when you fill in that form. They privately quote the refugee on transporting goods. So I've got this secret info service. We don't charge for it at all whatsoever, but it's kind of like an underground thing.
在那个页面的右侧，我有一个小表格，这样你可以以难民的身份放入你的信息。然后有秘密的喜欢难民的人，愿意在后台帮助他们，当填完那个表格时会收到一封电子邮件。他们私下给难民运输货物的报价。所以我有了这个秘密信息服务。我们完全不收费，但它有点像地下东西。
So we've got that for all sorts of services, like financial advice for people needing to get their pension money out of the country and that kind of thing. We've got it for-- we're busy with selling cars now, if you're putting your property on the market. But yeah, we're not very well liked. So it's so ironic. If we weren't persecuted before, we certainly are now. [LAUGHS]
所以我们有各种各样的服务，比如为需要把养老金弄出国家的人提供的金融建议之类的。我们有它——我们现在忙于卖车，如果你要把你的财产上市。但是的，我们不是很受欢迎。所以这太讽刺了。如果我们之前没有受到迫害，我们现在肯定受到了。[笑]
So it's almost like a self-fulfilling prophecy. Extend the executive order, extend the offer for refugee program, and then also spark a bit of a race war as a result.
所以这几乎像是一个自我实现的预言。延长行政命令，扩大难民计划的提议，然后结果也引发了一场种族战争。
Did you feel identified with other white people in South Africa in this way before?
你之前有没有这样认同过南非的其他白人？
No. No, no. This is a completely new phenomenon for all of us. I don't think a group has ever been so tight-knit as this group is in this country, ever. In fact, I think it's akin to your MAGA on a very tiny scale. You know that feeling of those people that group together and would have TPUSA and all those sort of things going on, and they would all flock to the rallies and whatever and that vibe, is that spark of excitement? Well, we've got the same thing going on here on a much smaller scale. It's actually quite sweet.
不。不，不。这是一个对我们所有人来说全新的现象。我不认为在这个国家有哪个群体像这个群体这样团结。事实上，我认为这类似于你们规模非常小的“MAGA”。你知道那些聚在一起的人的感觉，会有TPUSA和所有那些事情，他们都会涌向集会等等，那种氛围，那种兴奋的火花？嗯，我们在这里有同样的事情发生，规模小得多。实际上很可爱。
I'd been focused on whether large numbers of South Africans would be allowed to come to the US. I hadn't imagined just how much the possibility of them coming here would change their lives, even if they never left.
我一直专注于是否有大量的南非人会被允许来美国。我没想象到他们来这里的可能性会改变他们的生活，即使他们从未离开。
I've got so many new friends, so many new friends. 18 hours a day, seven days a week-- I live, eat, sleep, and breathe what's going on here.
我有很多新朋友，很多新朋友。每天18小时，一周七天——我生活、吃饭、睡觉、呼吸这里发生的事情。
Do you feel like it's a big part of your identity now, that you're an Amerikaner or that you're part of this group that's eligible for this program?
你觉得现在这是一个很大的身份部分吗，你是“Amerikaner”或者你是符合这个计划的群体的一部分？
Totally. I'm loving it. I'll be honest. It's given me a newfound purpose. I feel very honored and privileged to have made a difference. It's like you take something on, and it actually works.
完全是。我爱死它了。说实话。它给了我一个新的目标。我很荣幸并有特权能做出改变。这就像你承担了一些事情，它实际上奏效了。
A few weeks ago, seven months after the executive order, I got a text from Sam. "I can't chat to anyone in the media at the moment." I went to the Amerikaners website, and it had changed. It now said, "Amerikaners is an official referral partner for the US Refugee Admissions Program." Sam couldn't talk to me anymore because she was now officially working with the US State Department. Amerikaners, this group she had invented, was helping the US government identify eligible refugees to the United States. Sam was right, and I was wrong.
几周前，行政命令出台七个月后，我收到萨姆的一条短信。“我目前无法与任何媒体聊天。”我去了“Amerikaners”网站，它已经变了。它现在写着：“Amerikaners是美国难民录取计划的官方推荐合作伙伴。”萨姆无法再跟我聊天，因为她现在正式与美国国务院合作。“Amerikaners”，她发明的这个群体，正在帮助美国政府识别符合条件的来美难民。萨姆是对的，我是错的。
The US government is processing refugee applicants in Pretoria right now at record speeds. I'm hearing people are being processed within weeks. Everything about the way the program is structured, it's the way Sam imagined it would go. To qualify, you do not need to be Afrikaner. You have to be from a racial minority population in South Africa, i.e. everyone except Black people. You do not need to provide documentation of past persecution. The chant "kill the Boer" qualifies as credible fear of future persecution. And you do not have to flee, as other refugees do. You can be processed for resettlement from your home.
美国政府目前正在比勒陀利亚以破纪录的速度处理难民申请。我听说人们在几周内就被处理了。关于该项目结构的一切，正是萨姆想象的那样。要获得资格，你不需要是南非荷兰人。你必须是南非的种族少数群体，即除了黑人以外的每一个人。你不需要提供过去迫害的文件。“杀掉布尔人”的口号算作对未来迫害的可信恐惧。而且你不必像其他难民那样逃离。你可以从家里接受重新安置处理。
I haven't talked to Sam in a while now. I'm not even sure where she is. Is she here or there? I do know, from talking to her before, a little bit about what she pictures her life here will be like.
我现在有一阵子没和萨姆谈过了。我甚至不知道她在哪里。她是在这里还是那里？我从之前和她的交谈中，对她想象中在这里的生活有一点了解。
Where in the States will you go? Do you know?
你会去美国的哪里？你知道吗？
Well, we're not sure where we would initially be relocated to, but I'm keen on North Carolina myself.
嗯，我们不确定最初会被重新安置到哪里，但我自己对北卡罗来纳感兴趣。
Why?
为什么？
Where are you based?
你住在哪里？
In New York.
在纽约。
I don't know. I've got this penchant for mountains. And I'm thinking if I go way into western North Carolina, I'm sure, where that's the Appalachians and-- I'm thinking that'll suit. So if I sell my little household goodies and my car and my whatever, I'm going to go with this tiny wallet with a few dollars in it. And then we hit the ground running. We've got to get ourselves working and doing all sorts of amazing things to earn a living when we get there. So we'll do that as a team, me and my boys.
我不知道。我对山有一种偏好。我在想如果我深入北卡罗来纳州西部，我确定，那是阿巴拉契亚山脉，我想那会适合。所以如果我卖掉我的小家当和车以及无论什么，我会带着这个钱包，里面有几美元。然后我们就开始工作。我们得让我们自己工作并做各种了不起的事情来维持生计。所以我们会作为一个团队去做，我和我的儿子们。
A new American archetype-- I think about Sam Busa this way now. And I think of her often. Every week, every few days, the president puts out a big declaration, a broad intention of things he'd like to see in the world-- an executive order on paper straws or a rant against Tylenol, the Riviera of the Middle East. And it becomes the job of the people who work for the president to figure out the practical details of if and how these things could actually happen.
一种新的美国原型——我现在这样想萨姆·布萨。我经常想起她。每周，每几天，总统都会发布一个大的声明，一个他想在世界上看到的广泛意图——关于纸吸管的行政命令，或者对泰诺、中东里维埃拉的抨击。总统雇佣的人的工作就是弄清楚如果这些事情真的发生以及如何发生的实际细节。
But then there are also people like Sam, an ordinary person who's not in the government, but who is tireless, skilled, and paying attention, someone with the confidence to say, I think this is what you mean here, right? When the administration issued this executive order in February, this wasn't the plan. They didn't know Sam was out there. She didn't know they were going to do this. But once the opportunity existed, there was Sam, willing to work with what was there to make this a reality, to turn it into a win.
但也有像萨姆这样的人，一个不在政府里的普通人，但不知疲倦、技术娴熟、关注细节，一个有自信说“我想这就是你的意思，对吧？”的人。当政府在二月发布这份行政命令时，这不是计划。他们不知道萨姆在那里。她不知道他们会这样做。但一旦机会存在，萨姆就在那里，愿意利用现有的东西使其成为现实，使其转化为胜利。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show. Nancy Updike edited her story. Just this week, the Trump administration published its official number of how many refugees the United States is going to take in the next year. The number is 7,500, a record low. And usually, the number is for people from all over the world. This year, it'll mostly just be South Africans.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人之一。南希·厄普代克编辑了她的故事。就在本周，特朗普政府发布了官方数字，关于美国明年要接收多少难民。数字是7,500，历史最低。通常，这个数字是针对来自世界各地的人。今年，它大部分只是南非人。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike, Diane Wu, and Chana Joffe-Walt. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Suzanne Gaber, Sophie Gill, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, and Julie Whitaker. Our Managing Editor's Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor's David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克、戴安·吴和查娜·乔菲-沃尔特制作。今天节目的人员包括Phia Bennin、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Suzanne Gaber、Sophie Gill、Katherine Rae Mondo、Stowe Nelson、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala和Julie Whitaker。我们的主编是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Adrian Allman, Angel Heard, Laynasia Crew, Diundra Norman, Jon Nelson, Sandile Swane, Timothy Young and Global Refuge, Chris George, Brian Kahn, Sara Joffe, and Sherrilyn Ifill. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. A reminder that if you like our show, if you listen to us a lot, please consider signing up as a This American Life Partner. Do it for the stuff you get, or do it simply because you want us to be able to keep making the show. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
今天特别感谢Adrian Allman、Angel Heard、Laynasia Crew、Diundra Norman、Jon Nelson、Sandile Swane、Timothy Young和Global Refuge、Chris George、Brian Kahn、Sara Joffe和Sherrilyn Ifill。《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。提醒一下，如果你喜欢我们的节目，如果你经常收听我们，请考虑注册成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴。为你得到的福利去做，或者仅仅因为你想让我们能够继续制作节目。加入：thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。
Thanks this week to Life Partners Roland Moore, Mark Kim, Christine Woodhouse, and Ross Boucher.
本周感谢生活合作伙伴Roland Moore、Mark Kim、Christine Woodhouse和Ross Boucher。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who, for some reason, always gets lots of questions from people this time of year about trick or treating.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生，不知何故，每年这个时候总是从人们那里得到关于不给糖就捣蛋的大量问题。
I'm 56. Aren't I too old? Or am I allowed to bring my dogs?
我56岁了。我太老了吗？或者我可以带上我的狗吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。